في المقابل ده وزير الخارجيه الايرانيه
حسين امير عبد الله يان الدول الاوروبيه
كافه للابتعاد عن ما وصفها بمواقفه غير
بناء وغير منطقيه والا تتخذ خطوات يمكن ان
تكون لها تدعيات جسيمه وفق تعبيره واضاف
الوزير الايراني في تصريح له انه في حال
اتخاذ الدول الاوروبيه قرارا ضد مؤسسه
السياديه مثل الحرس الثوري فاستشهد ردا
قويا ومؤثرا من جانب طهران حسب تعبير
عزف حدود الدومه
منذ شهرين تدخلات من جانب الدول الغربيه
في شؤوننا الداخليه واستغلال الوضع في
ايران وحذرنا الدول الاوروبيه بشكل جدي
انه في حاله اتخذت قرارا ضد مؤسسه سياديه
مثل الحرس الثوري فسيكون ردنا بالمقابل
قويا ومؤثرا قرار البرلمان الاوروبي
الاخير بشان الحرس الثوري الايراني متسرع
وغير منطقي وعاطفي ويتعارض مع القوانين
والاعراف الدوليه اكدت خلال اتصالات مع
المسؤولين الاوروبيين ان عليهم الابتعاد
عن المواقف غير البناء وغير المنطقيه بشان
ايران وان لا تتخذ بلدانهم خطوات يمكن ان
تكون لها تداعيات جسيمه
كما قال المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الايرانيه
ناصر كنعاني ان العقوبات التي فرضتها دول
والاتحاد الاوروبي وبريطاني على ايران
انما تدل على غضب هذه الدول سبب فشل هذه
زعزعه الاستقرار في ايران واعتبر كنعاني
ان طهران تحافظ على حق الرد على هذه
العقوبات وهذه السياسات الفاشله مضيفا
انها ستصدر قريبا قائمه من العقوبات على
مجموعه من منتهيك حقوق الانسان ودعمي
الارهاب في بريطانيا والاتحاد الاوروبي